the major motion picture studios lost an
estimated 6.1 billion dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
it was well worth doing prison time for
The Pirate Bay this was the final Battle
Cry of a Pirate Bay co-founder of
Frederick nage after getting raided by
the police multiple times being fined to
46 million kroner and being thrown in
prison alongside some of the most vile
people on Earth Frederick was the only
person in his entire prison that was
there for a virtual crime everyone else
there was convicted for robbery assault
manslaughter or worse but things weren't
too bad in prison says Frederick he
immersed himself with reading letters
from fans about how much The Pirate Bay
meant to them this isn't to say that
Frederick willingly turned himself in
though like any normal human being he
very much dreaded the idea of going to
jail and was on the run for several
years as one of the most hated
individuals by media organizations
around the world but ever eventually the
law did catch up with him putting him
behind bars but this only strengthened
Frederick's personal conviction as the
letter is reminded him of why he did
everything in the first place unlike
other piracy website creators Frederick
wasn't trying to make money or get rich
or screw over big companies he had
founded the Pirate Bay out of principle
the idea that information culture and
the knowledge should be shared freely
around the world without the
interference of corporate greed
bureaucracy or political influence in
fact Frederick had been fighting for
this cause long before he co-founded a
Pirate Bay or gained any sort of
notoriety before his pirate bay days
Frederick was part of a Swedish
anti-copyright group that went around
the world engaging in piracy debates and
giving lectures about the right to
information this is where Frederick met
the other Founders godfretswartam and
Peterson and together they would go on
to create one of the most controversial
yet legendary sites of all time so
here's how The Pirate Bay went from
being an ideological effort to becoming
an international icon despite police
raids jail time and the efforts of the
media industry at Large
[Music]
foreign
Bay dates back to the late 1970s and the
early 1980s to the country of Sweden
where all three of our protagonists were
born not much is known about any of the
founders childhoods but from what we do
know it wasn't anything to brag about
Frederick was the oldest of the bunch
having been born on April 27 1978 in the
city of yonshipping Sweden there's
rumors that he dropped out of high
school and it appears that he just
stumbled through his life one day at a
time a similar story could be said about
a godfred as well who was the youngest
of the bunch having been born on October
1984. godfred was your classic computer
nerd hacker of the 1990s and 2000s think
Dennis nedry from Jurassic Park and then
there was Peter Saunder who was the only
one that would be considered somewhat
Successful by modern society but this
wasn't to say that his childhood was any
better Peter was born on September 13
1978 and it would have all Sweden at
first his life wasn't all that bad his
mother was a staff consultant at a large
company and his father was a traveling
mechanic but all of this fell apart when
Peter's parents got a divorce when he
was just 8 years old his mother would
become a clinically delusional as she
developed psychosis which resulted in
the family constantly moving all across
Scandinavia unsurprisingly Peter would
end up dropping out of school in his
teens but there was one Saving Grace
computers computers were Peter's wanted
and the only escape from his harsh
reality and that this led to him
becoming quite a skilled programmer
ironically if he had this same childhood
in modern times it's likely that he
would have become a lifeless social
media addict like mice anyways things
were different back then the people
spending all of their time on computers
weren't endlessly scrolling through Tick
Tock there were enthusiasts learning how
to code and hack systems and that this
would catch the attention of German
technology company Simons Simons is the
people behind many of the it systems
used at hospitals and they would hire
Peter to upgrade their patient
registration system from being
fingerprint based to being a retinal
based that seemed like a pretty good gig
at first glance but Peter couldn't not
stand it at Simon's after he joined he
would discover that his development
efforts were being used to identify and
Deport illegal immigrants leading them
to do Unthinkable things you see it many
of these immigrants would burn their
fingers on kitchen stoves before
visiting the hospital to avoid being
identified this was actually one of the
main reasons that Simons wanted to
switch to a retinal system but this
simply gave Peter nightmares about
immigrants poking out their eyes like
Victor quill he tried to take it up with
his managers but this simply gave him
the title of being negative and
difficult to work with being drained
from work every day the only Solace
Peter found was during the evenings when
he scrolled through online forms leading
him to discover the world of piracy
foreign
privacy Journey started with Tim
swapping music and movies on invite-only
servers which led him to meeting fellow
scallywagon Frederick nage Frederick
introduced Peter to the file sharing
movement and to the nearly founded
anti-copyright organization pirate to be
wrong or the pirate Bureau hirat biron
was founded on August 1st 2003 by a
bunch of societal outcasts just like
Peter Frederick and godfred their goal
was to make information available to
people of all backgrounds in stature and
to promote Free Speech above everything
else not saying I agree with how they
went about doing this but honestly it
does seem like their intentions were way
more pure than most of the people who
actually control the world today with
this idea in mind the group got to work
some members tried opposing Pro
copyright lobbyist groups others travel
the world and gave lectures on radio and
a TV our Trio decided to create a
website this was specifically
Frederick's idea he wanted to create a
Bighorn tracker and he would recruit the
help of Peter and it got rid for the I.T
and the coding side of things given the
relative Simplicity of the website Peter
and Gottfried had this up and running in
no time and piratviron would launch the
website on September 15 2003. this was
actually just one of many websites that
this Trio launched moving into 2004
Frederick and Gottfried would create a
full-on internet service provider and a
web hosting company called prq don't be
a fool though this was no ATT with prq
Frederick and gotford looked to give an
online voice to anyone and everyone
regardless of what they stood for or did
this included some unheard and repressed
voices but it also included a bunch of
creeps literally there were a bunch of
forms hosted on prq that advocated for
how should I say it unorthodox
relationships though Frederick and
godfredit definitely did it not agree
with everything that was hosted under
platform they defended all of their
customers equally citing freedom of
speech something else that sparked a
bunch of controversy was yet another one
of these Duos Ventures America's dumbest
soldiers honestly this one was quite
distasteful the website consisted of a
list of deceased American soldiers and
it prompted people to vote on how dumb
their debts were little to say this site
did a not stay up for very long while
these other Ventures definitely caused a
scene by themselves it turned out that
the Trio's original Venture would have
the greatest sticking power and luckily
for them it was pretty cheap to run
after all the Pirate Bay didn't actually
have any foul hosting or server declined
to downloading abilities built in the
site Simply Connected people with a
library of links and all the downloading
took place using peer-to-peer protocols
so the trio just had to ensure that they
had enough server capacity to handle all
of the search volume indexing sorting
and filtering but to their surprise it
didn't take long for this itself to
become unmanageable
foreign
Bay exploded in popularity and it became
abundantly clear that this could no
longer be treated as a side project so
in October of 2004 the trio would
transition the site into being a
standalone non-profit based in
Seychelles though this is disputed if
you also have no idea what this place is
you're not alone the Seychelles is an
East African country that's composed of
115 islands and it just so happened to
be the perfect place to set up a shell
company now they had an entity all they
needed was infrastructure and Derm Carl
lundstrom this guy wasn't one of five
heirs to the wasabread fortune I've
actually never heard of this company but
they're super big they're extremely
popular across Scandinavia and they're
actually the largest crisp bread
producer in the world by the time Carl
turned to 22 this company would be sold
to a Swiss pharmaceutical company called
Santos which made crawl a Mega
millionaire by the time that most of us
would even graduate call launch Carl
were to turn around and use this wealth
to fund a variety of extreme political
movements and and it wasn't long till he
crossed paths with our protagonists he
would agree to provide the Pirate Bay
with all of the required servers and
infrastructure and before you knew it
the Pirate Bay would become a fully
funded Venture making copyright holders
around the world cry but they weren't
crying for long they were heard and they
were hurt bad Hollywood claims that in
2006 alone piracy cost them 6.1 billion
dollars and the biggest corporate
enabling this asinine Behavior was the
Swedish site that was just one Google
search away the Pirate Bay naturally
Hollywood wanted Revenge they wanted
justice so they marched over to the
Swedish authorities and demanded that
the Pirate Bay be taken down as soon as
possible this was met with a chuckle
from Sweden I'm not even kidding you see
Sweden is surprisingly chill about
copyright and patents in fact they have
a full-on political party called the
pirate party whose entire focus is to
reform copyright law Hollywood was
gobsmacked and they would take their
grievances to the good old us of a
surely there are hundreds of millions of
lobbying dollars would actually earn
them some respect from the American
authorities and they were right the US
would turn around and go yo sweet in him
you better shut down those mischievous
Rascals you got there you don't want us
to bring out the stick and impose it
create sanctions through the world
create organization right and to that
Sweden would respond your wish is our
Command and that they would go ahead and
rate The Pirate Bay service in Stockholm
on May 31st 2006. there was so much
equipment that the Swedish police would
end up filling three trucks worth of
computer equipment and servers surely
this would put an end to the nonsense
they thought but
um The Pirate Bay would be back up in
just three days
thank you
[Music]
you're probably wondering how is the
trio able to restart the Pirate Bay so
quickly well the answer is that the
Pirate Bay is nothing it's really just a
massive Excel sheet with a bunch of
links in fact the entirety of the party
Bay can be compressed into a 90 megabyte
zip file so they didn't have to maintain
a massive convoluted code bases and
repositories or enterprise resource
planning software all of the servers and
Equipment were simply there to support
the extraordinary traffic so as soon as
they were able to find a new
infrastructure they were able to upload
their tiny zip file and go live in no
time
this time they chose to put their
servers in a more discreet location
somewhere in the Netherlands so that the
police couldn't just turn around and
raid them again Hollywood was triggered
Not only was The Pirate Bay back up and
running but the police raid had simply
drawn even more attention to the website
clearly Hollywood didn't have much power
in Sweden so they turned their focus to
American companies they might not be
able to shut down the Pirate Bay but
maybe they could prevent you from
accessing it they started working with
Google Facebook Microsoft and isps to
suppress the sharing and searching of
part bailings but this only made things
worse
here's the thing when you tell people
not to do something that's when they
want to do it and this couldn't be truer
with the Pirate Bay just because
Facebook or Google suppressed Pirate Bay
links doesn't mean that you don't have
to be a rocket scientist to go directly
to the Pirate Bay website and search up
whatever you want and this is exactly
what was happening by 2008 The Pirate
Bay became the 97th most visited website
on the entire internet and they were
even having talks about selling the
website to Global gaming Factory xab for
eight and a half million dollars it was
becoming abundantly clear that there was
only one way to stop this madness
distract the tent on January 31st 2008
Swedish prosecutors would file charges
against the godfred Frederick Peter and
Carl from the very beginning this was a
decided case pirate-based lawyers tried
to defend it that the Pirate Bay was
simply posting links and that it wasn't
actually encouraging or enabling piracy
if you want you could use the site to
share open source software or themes
while this was technically true I mean
let's face it these guys were literally
part of pirate biron and all of this was
completely intentional so their argument
was quickly shut down and on April 17
2009 all four of them would be sentenced
to one year in jail along with a 30
million Corner fine which is about three
and a half million dollars
they would try appealing and this did
result in shorter prison sentences
Frederick would go down to 10 months
Peter would go down to eight months and
the Carl would go down to four months
but the appeal also came with a larger
fine of 46 million kroner or six and a
half million dollars the walls were
closing in and there was only one thing
that Trio could do get on the Run
if you're wanted to buy Hollywood at
large for causing billions of dollars
worth of lost Revenue you would think
that it would be a good idea to lay low
but all three of our protagonists would
do the exact opposite Frederick would
run away to Laos slash Thailand and he
would create yet another of our sharing
site called The Big House in 2011.
apparently this website was supposed to
comply with copyright rules but you can
take that for what you will not only did
Frederick launch another site but he
would regularly cross the border between
Laos and Thailand because he had
residences in both countries in fact he
crossed the border almost 30 times
before getting caught in November of
2014. at which point he would be
deported back to Sweden where he spent
200 days in jail at least Frederick
created another site that was legal at
least on the front Gottfried on the
other hand would run away to Cambodia
and go full-on Supply mode and become a
regular hacker for Wikileaks he would
literally infiltrate Denmark's Social
Security and a driver's license
databases I don't think that you'd be
surprised to hear that when he was
caught in August of 2012 his prison
sentence would be upped to three and a
half years but he would be let go after
three years and finally as for Peter
Well my man straight up joined the
finland's pirate party and ran for
European Parliament in the 2014 election
let's just say he was arrested a few
days after the election and he had to
serve five months in jail by late 2014
all three founders were not only
disconnected from their pirate debate
but they were all straight up in jail so
prosecutors figured that this was the
perfect time to end this once and for
all on December 9th 2014 the police
would conduct yet another raid on the
Pirate Bay and they would shut down the
original website for good surely the
founders could not pull any quick ones
this time right
well they were right none of the
founders were to try to restart the
pirate Bayer after their jail sentence
Frederick would return to Laos and to
get a job in it Peter would work on a
micropayment system called flatter and a
messaging platform called hemless
Gottfried would also return to the I.T
sector and move on from The Pirate Bay
yes the founders were done and out but
there were thousands of people wanting
to carry on the Legacy remember how we
talked about it being really easy to
store the entirety of the Pirate Bay
well it turns out that a lot of people
had been regularly saving copies of the
website so whenever one version of the
website is taken down it's just a matter
of time until another one pops up with a
slightly different domain at first
prosecutors tried taking on these
websites one after another but and
quickly became evident that this was
simply a waste of time effort and
resources because the legacy of the
Pirate Bay was truly Unstoppable
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Pirate Bay started off as a project
created by a bunch of Misfits and
outcasts but it quickly turned into the
icon of the internet and the worst
nightmare of the copyright holders
Hollywood tried burying it shredding it
and burning it but in the end they
decided to just give it all away because
what other choice did they really have
also if you're wondering about what
happened to the Fine well here's what
Peter had to say about it during the
press conference following a verdict
Peter would hold up a sign saying that
he was copyright holders 31 million
kroner and that that confession it is
all that copyright holders would ever
get if that wasn't clear enough you
would go on to clarify that he didn't
have the money and even if he did he'd
rather burn everything and not even give
them the ashes and that right there is
the legendary history of the Pirate Bay
do you guys think piracy is moral
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think that debate is an internet
Legend and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community such as for
the video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions actually answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one